why should our soldiers be fighting
radicals in a civil war in afghanistan
we've got our own on capitol hill it's
an unbelievable statement right there if
you can draw the parallel between
enemies abroad and enemies at home you
can treat enemies at home as we treated
enemies abroad
this is dangerous stuff for many on the
left they're happy that we are
redirecting all of our focus from
enemies abroad to enemies within this is
a serious serious problem
there are a lot of people on the left
who are far more concerned with the
enemies within than with the enemies
abroad this is why you saw the spectacle
of general mark milley of the joint
chiefs of staff
saying to congress that he was deeply
deeply concerned about the roots of
white rage he had to have his soldiers
laura they had to read about max kennedy
to learn about critical race theory and
the roots of white rage we definitely
needed that
we needed lloyd austin the secretary of
defense
talking about how we needed to diversify
the military this was a key priority the
wokification of the military this was
this was key not actually winning wars
by the way who's gonna get fired for
this anybody bueller
bueller no one's gonna get fired for
this
if you're this incompetent in your job
you'd be fired forthwith like within
seconds
and these these
jackasses have made a mockery like an
absolute mockery of the sacrifices of
the brave men and women of the american
armed services who sacrificed in many
cases in thousands of cases their lives
in tens of thousands of cases their body
parts their livelihoods their mental
health in order to establish american
security on the ground in afghanistan
and provide us a base to fight terrorism
from and yes to add to the humanitarian
values that were in afghanistan
right those people have been abjectly
betrayed by this administration i'm
getting letters from them all day long
the last several days
yeah and this administration they they
were focusing on what really mattered
and that was the threat of white
supremacy within that was the threat of
domestic terrorism in the united states
okay so
the the there are bad people in the
united states they exist but the
incredible
conflation like the left knows what's
happening here they do the hard left
understand that what they've just done
is humiliate themselves globally like
really humiliate themselves that's
that's what this represents and so they
have to come up with an alternative
narrative and the alternative narrative
is that the taliban
yeah they're bad but we've got bad
people here too
the taliban are really bad
but you know what we have an american
taliban we need to fight we need to
bring those soldiers home not to as so
many on the right seem to think send
them to the border
or redeploy them to the south china sea
no the left would like to bring
everybody home focus all of our
resources internally and this is also
true with our moral capital it used to
be the united states exported its moral
capital right we had all this moral
capital we were the most
free country most powerful country in
the history of the world in the history
of the world the most tolerant and
diverse country in the history of the
world by the way also
and we were exporting that moral capital
abroad
sometimes to great effect sometimes to
no effect
and sometimes to help build nascent
democracy in places like iraq and yes at
the beginning in afghanistan or
maybe we were doing it unsuccessfully in
afghanistan but successfully in germany
and japan right the united states has a
long history of exporting our moral
capital elsewhere
but now because the left has decided we
have no moral capital instead we have to
take all of our reasons we have to we
have to stop interfering in world
affairs we have to let our enemies take
advantage of the vacuum that we create
we have to focus all of our moral
resources at home we have to rebuild our
moral capital and rebuilding that moral
capital starts at home we have to make
sure that all of our public school
students learn about their white
privilege we have to ensure that america
sees its dire history of racism sexism
bigotry and homophobia we have to
rebuild morally speaking and that means
taking on the real enemy the real enemy
is not tens of thousands of miles away
the real enemy is not in afghanistan the
real enemy is not terrorists or china
the real enemy is here within that's the
enemy that we have to fight according to
members of the hard left so you have the
specter of stephen colbert he's
unbelievable likening trump voters to
the taliban this happened two nights ago
american troops cannot
and should not
be fighting in a war and dying in a war
that afghan forces are not willing to
fight for themselves
he's right
we've had troops there for 20 years
they fought
they sacrificed their families
sacrificed so that we wouldn't have a
terrorist attack
in america planned in a foreign country
why should our soldiers be fighting
radicals in a civil war in afghanistan
we've got our own on capitol hill
we've got our own on capitol hill you
see the people who are outside the
capitol that was what that picture was
the people who are outside the capitol
building on january 6th they are the
same as the american taliban they're the
they are just the same thing they're the
same
oh are they now
fascinating so if that were the case
and by the way that's that's what he
wants right the idea is that we have to
redeploy the american military against
people who disagree with with stephen
colbert that's that's
that's an unbelievable statement right
there
okay so by the way even in that
statement he acknowledges why we were
supposed to remain in afghanistan to
fight terrorism because guess what that
threat has not ended and now it's going
to be reconstituted in afghanistan but
that's a side point for the radical left
the enemy is not the taliban those are
people who are very far away engaged in
a civil war the enemy is you the enemy
is people who think like you who
disagree with stephen colbert he doesn't
mean that we need the american military
there to put down
actual violent action only at the
capitol building no far from it the left
conflates all those people you see the
left is not interested in separating off
the people who engaged in violent
activity and who were duly arrested at
the capitol building
the left believes that everyone who's
outside the capital is the same as
everybody who actually violated the law
they believe that everybody who voted
for donald trump is the same as the
people outside the capitol and this is
what the left does
we have violent terrorists in the united
were states
murdered on that day
and the answer is that no actual people
were murdered on that day the only
person who was actually killed on that
day as in actively killed on that day
was ashley babbitt who was one of the
protesters one of the rioters right she
was engaging in criminal activity
that's the and the entire place was
cleared within three hours and the uh
and the government went on so if that
sounds a lot like the taliban it's
because you're a crazy person it's
because you're out of your damned mind
there's also
there are also gradations of people
doing bad things and believing terrible
things okay the people who invaded the
capitol building and the belief that the
election was illegitimate are not
remotely on the level of human beings in
afghanistan who wish to crowd women back
into basement keep them there as sex
slaves for decades on end make sure they
can't go to school make sure that
everybody lives under the most brutal
and violent form of sharia law
like can we make any sort of gradations
here can we say that even if we think
that the january 6th riots or an act of
evil that that is a different level of
evil than people who are literally
living in stone age barbarism and
murdering people in order to ensure that
stone age barbarism rules
are there no gradations here at all
according to the left there aren't and
in fact the people in the united states
who did this are much more dangerous to
us than the taliban
they're much more natural like because 9
11 never happened you say 9 11 was a
figment of your imagination
9 11
in fact what happened on january 6th is
worse than 911 in the minds of the left
because it came from here
even though it resulted again
in no murders
that that that is not to downplay the
evil of that but to the comparison to
911 itself is idiotic but to the left
it's worse it's worse than 9 11. 9 11
basically never happened according to
the left so we don't have to worry about
threats abroad anymore those are done
according to stephen colbert the real
threat is you the real threat is people
who think like you
and by the way if you don't think that
they are conflating everybody if you
think that colbert is just talking about
the rioters you're wrong malcolm nance
who you'll recall i debated on uh on
bill maher and i pointed out that
malcolm nance has a really really nasty
habit of conflating the people who
engaged in criminal activity on january
6 with everyone who voted for trump now
malcolm nance has a new theory his
theory is that trump voters everywhere
are going to engage in an actual violent
civil war which would explain why we
need to pull out from afghanistan to
activate against those people here's
malcolm nance doing what he does most
often which is claim that he has inside
intelligence information suggesting that
a massive civil war is about to break
out in the united states led by trump
these guys view themselves as this
fanciful group of patriotic freedom
fighters the second coming of the sons
of liberty and there are many of them
who are preparing for civil war right
now all the shame that we tried to give
them after january 6 that's gone there
are many of them right now that are
ready to fight and we're seeing
politicians in the state houses and the
capital who are actually you know
pushing them subliminally to fight this
doltish claude here's what he had to say
right before that quote the republican
party is more like shin fine and the
relationship between shin fi and the
irish nationalist party and the irish
republican army provisional irish
republican army terrorist group who
called themselves freedom fighters and
insurgents and had americans american
congressmen sending them money to buy
you know heavy machine guns
he said the idea here again from the
left increasingly is that the taliban
are not bad right or at least they're
not really a threat maybe they're not
great but really should we worry about
them the real threat is everyone who
voted republican everyone who voted
trump those people are the real threat
those are the people we deeply have to
worry about michael moore made this
absolutely clear so michael moore is a
is a complete buffoon he tweeted out
their taliban our taliban everybody's
got a taliban they're at their best when
they confiscate the halls of power and
then he tweeted a picture of the taliban
sitting at the
seat of the national government and then
the uh buffoonish idiots who invaded the
capitol building on january 6th
um
you will note that the people
in the upper picture the taliban
they're going to murder probably tens of
thousands of human beings they are also
going to
retain this dictatorship until
presumably the end of time
and uh the people at the bottom are a
bunch of clods
in buffalo hats
who were cleared out of the capital and
arrested within three hours
those are not comparable
those are not remotely comparable
but if you can draw the parallel the
left has been doing this for for 20
years by the way but but now it's really
kicked into high gear since trump
if you can draw the parallel between
enemies abroad and enemies at home you
can treat enemies at home as we traded
to enemies abroad
this is dangerous stuff
because for members of the radical left
and increasingly the mainstream left if
the idea is we rebuild moral capital by
destroying the enemies here at home this
is how tyranny happens this is how
authoritarianism happens if you are
justified in freedom i mean after all we
literally fought the taliban
we unleash the drones on them we've
probably killed tens of thousands of
members of the taliban over the years
if
if there's an equivalent group in the
united states to the taliban we would
have to treat them
like we treated the taliban would we not
members of the left are eager and happy
about that of the hard left
if that sentiment grows that that really
is a threat to the future of the country
on a broad scale but we have many
threats to the future of the country we
have the radicals on the left who think
that everybody who disagrees with them
is the american taliban it must be
thoroughly destroyed
we have a group of people on the left
who believe that government ought to
rule all of our lives on the basis of
the slim the slimmest and thinnest of
reeds like at this point the kovid
pandemic
we have people on the left who believe
that the pathway back to american moral
capital is to completely destroy the
american economic system by burdening it
with the greatest spending binge in the
history of of anything
and to destroy america's credibility on
the foreign stage
decline is a choice the left is choosing
it
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wire are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment